hello everyone i'm very happy to be here
so this is actually my first talk a big
talk at some kind of meet up
so
yes i'm very happy um i will talk today
about
explainability in nlp models so natural
language processing models
yes i'm currently in the middle of my
work on this topic so um i can't
guarantee you any completeness
um yeah i'm working um my way through
that topic and if you have any additions
or remarks um i'm i'll be very happy if
you could approach me later
um
maybe some words about myself i'm
larissa um i'm a great fan of pi data
southwest and the open source python
community
i studied political science and data
science in mannheim before i started
working as a data scientist at cervantes
in heidelberg
in my daily work i'm a lot concerned
with business processes and optimization
of them
um but i'm also very into yeah the nlp
topic in my private time i like to chat
about ai in science fiction so um yeah
we can also chat about that later too
so what is explainable ai maybe you've
heard about that term maybe you haven't
in general it describes the processes
and methods
used to understand your your ai systems
better so as the ai systems more and
more get like into black box models and
the need arises to understand them
really
and the goal is to achieve accuracy
fairness to reduce biases and to better
understand the outcomes
i say ai systems
because as you can see here
the model is not the only parameter in
explainability so you want to want to
understand the whole system behind it
um
but i think the first steps in this
system so the data the setup features
instruction and structure and they are
already quite visible so you can display
the data you can make graphs out of it
you can explain the setup the parameters
but the model and how the decisions were
created it's very hard to grasp so this
is why i will focus on the last two
steps here
and why is explainability even important
so why bother about it as you can see
here a lot of stakeholders in the ai
process are interested into
explainability
and there are a lot of reasons why it is
important i don't want to go
into detail here but
keep in mind it's not only good for the
end user
to have explainability they might ask
more questions about it but it's also
for you as maybe as a developer maybe as
a stakeholder here in this process to
understand what is happening inside of
your black box
explainability is also closely connected
to ai ethics
which is
maybe more interesting to the regulators
on the top left
but
this could be a whole talk on its own so
i don't want to go into detail here
right so common approaches for
explainable ai in nlp in general i just
want to show you what explainable ai
methods there are so you can
divide it into global and local
explainability so global explainability
as you see on the top left hand side
explains
your
yeah impact explains how the decisions
were created
for your whole data set so
you get explanations fitting to all kind
of data points
local explainability on the other hand
side
only refers to like the single
prediction for this exact data point
and then you have
the different aspects of model agnostic
approaches and model specific approaches
model specific yeah as it already says
it's very dependent on the model so it
really depends on what kind of model
you're using maybe on the data type that
you're using
and model agnostic can be used with any
types of models and this is very
interesting for
the classical black box models as for
deep learning neural nets etc
there are two ways
how these model agnostic
approaches work so typically you have
your black box this black box is
complete with the whole data
pre-processing pipeline
up until your prediction outcomes
and you can have two techniques here you
can either
take one data point and permutate it so
change only small bits of it and then
have a look at the outcome what changes
and when and the outcome changes and
then you can calculate um correlations
and connections between those two steps
or you can take your original data as an
input and do the same so these are two
two techniques to tackle here
now i have
five very yeah concrete steps what you
can do
with
nlp data in terms of explainability so
you can use for example human
annotations i don't know if you ever
thought of it so imagine you have a data
set um it gets labeled by
yeah human co-workers and they they do a
classification by hand and on the same
step they are adding
reasons why they are adding this label
so they annotate your data set and you
can use it simply as another
dependent variable in your
classification step
and get there a sense
why this prediction or where this
prediction comes from but keep in mind
as you predict what you're predicting
here is not how the model comes to this
conclusion but how the model thinks
that the human co-worker
came to this labor
so it's a different kind of
explainability here not the model
explainability but maybe the data kind
of explainability
um then
second
second method you can use you can use um
the for example future importances or
the model structures so for example um i
have here uh example from the bird model
so birds is a yeah very common
um nlp
model where that is used
and here
the interpreter takes the third layer of
this very big model and makes it yeah
visible so you can feed it
feed a
sentence in and you get a
color rating
if a word is more important for the
meaning of the sentence
so
this is quite nice but it's only for one
layer of this i don't know 12 layer bird
model so you don't really get
the whole picture but you can see in
some details how the model is working
here
another
possibility could be here to simply use
understandable models this is maybe
um
yeah the the most straightforward
approach you could use
understandable models like decision
trees regressions etc
but if you have ever seen
nlp data it's not that easy because you
have a high dimensionality you have a
lot of features
and it's very difficult to display them
for example in a decision tree so it
really depends on your data when you can
transform it such that it fits to such
models it's really great to use them
and as i said you always could
yeah
remodel or kind of use the black box um
for
correlation so
maybe you have heard of this technique
so lime shape and le5
and they can all also be used for image
data but they work great for text data
so in the picture here you see
an example i really like the film the
actors fit perfectly the music was
impressive and this is my opinion on the
new dune movie if you have seen it and
the prediction here is quite right so
i'm very positive about the movie
and the sharp values here in this
example show which part of the sentence
contributed to the prediction outcome
how yeah how much so
it's yeah really
visual and
it also shows the global
impact
of these
yeah sentences so
the only difference between lime and
sharp they are
quite the same lyme computes
a local interpret
explainability so a local correlation
between words and the outcome and shap
can be yeah combined for a global
um
for a global value but it's way more
costly so it takes a longer time to
compute
and there's le5 and for those of you who
don't know what elie is the abbreviation
for it's explained like m5 which is i
think it fits quite good because
ellie
highlights single words um how they
contribute to the final prediction
ali is not completely model agnostic so
they i think it's heavily built on the
psych learn pipeline but
yeah you can use it for a lot of models
out there
and one last
method you could use you could always
use graphical representations so
especially when you're
training for example word vectors word
embeddings
um you could use them to display them on
a
on a grid and just print it out
the downside is you have to do a
dimensionality reduction because you
just can display it on 2d or 3d
but it's also a good a good method if
you're working on this
i can only recommend you i'm taking this
this example out
you can see here we are in layer 11 and
and this is the interactive website
where you can
have a look at how
the bird model in this case
answers faq questions and you can see
each step from layer 1 to layer 12 and
how the model moves around the words and
takes them into
yeah
into
correlation so it's very cool and you
can find the link in my presentation i
will upload it
later on
so these were
like my ideas for
tackling explainability for
for nlp models um i've just summarized
it to you so you can find it later in
the slides
what are now the main difficulties um
i have spoken of so
first you have the high number of
dimensions as you might already know you
have a high variability in models so you
could have like a bag of words
representation of your words you could
have embeddings
that you
want to feed into your model so this
variability leads to yeah difficulties
because i cannot say this is the one
solution that you should use here
um then the next problem is
a set of tokens is not equal to
variables so if you have the same token
in different positions in the text it
has a different meaning because of the
context because of the
yeah the contents of the whole text and
in this case you have to treat text more
like image data than numerical data and
this is something you have to remember
then it's very difficult to make the
transfer from local to global some
models can do this some other models
can't and it's important to keep that in
mind
yeah it's also difficult to show
something graphically because even if
you have word embeddings you have to
reduce the
dimensionality in order to show them you
don't want to print out all of your word
vectors into a dictionary size book
because yeah nobody can work with this
so you have to reduce complexity you
have to think about really good and
approachable ways to show this
and
i find this the most difficult
you have joint effects and effects of
absent words so you don't
only have tokens that are single words
but you have can have
for example
diagrams like two words together feeding
into
the model or you um or also absent words
have a meaning so if a word is missing
in a text it's also important that it's
missing but how can you show a missing
word so this is really i think this is
really a challenge
and yeah this is also in my
lessons learned list
so
my lessons learned with
explainability in nlp you have to
explain what you're showing here in
explainability so you
have to make it really transparent
i find it find it difficult to explain
absence words and also to here clarify
what is the difference between local
impact in this case and global impact
and the next yeah to do steps for me
i for my case i need to find a fitting
graphical representation
i need to reduce complexity for example
combining sharp values into categories
making it
more visible
and i need to include help texts because
those
features that i explained and that i
showed are not self-explanatory so you
need to guide the viewer here
and
this leads me to the end of my
presentation as i said here are all
links i will upload
the presentation to my github later it's
not there yet
i'm sorry
um but yeah if you have any questions
please approach me or write me on
twitter
yes and thank you
[Applause]